how would you guys like to have a bath
with me that's very intimate over
interview
[Applause]
hanukkah's I met about Ben Aria and we
are here in the heart of beautiful
Istanbul Turkey to experience a
traditional Turkish bath or a ham up and
while it's sometimes it's nice to do
things on your own it's even better when
you get to share the experience so I've
decided to find myself a strange man
here to have a bath with since her moms
are typically separated by gender I am
left with only being able to ask men to
join me at my bath we will find a man
for me to bed with we still have time
where are you from
Oh hold on to him poco why the question
for mainly for your father I am
experiencing my first Turkish bath very
shortly it's a cultural experience I was
wondering if you would like to take a
bath with me here is I said Allah baño
coño coño
literally around the corner down down
the street if you can do it we'll get
you in there too with Shaz and Abdi both
agreeing to join me on this adventure we
make our way to the incredible 300 year
old jail Olive hammam this is the type
of thing that hopefully decades from now
possibly in a month or so at one of your
funerals we can talk about this but you
never know death death comes when you
least expect it let's get on it here
before they back out let's go
[Music]
Meribah Ben Aria met of a van come on we
are one of the oldest Tom in all times
people don't have any much places to go
somewhere and spend their time a lot of
people come here places like that and
they spent their time inside and then
they left as a kind of new person it's
one of the biggest part of our culture
and we are trying to protect it and
after we get appropriately dressed we're
ready to start our treatment know your
treatment is going to be in three parts
first the hot room rest it's like a
sauna you're gonna get sweats like a 15
or 10 minutes it depends on your skin to
get your body to ready to transmit
after that our therapist will wash your
body to clean you from your sweats and
then he's gonna make a scrub like a ten
minutes on your body it's like a peeling
for your skin
how much dead skin is there
it both feels very good and yet it's a
little uncomfortable but in a good way
that's weird
oh and then he will wash you again and
while you're laying down on the hots
marble he will cover your body with the
bubble to get your skin most softly
again
I'm just very excited people he's going
for and then he's gonna make a massage
on you we call it for massage or you can
call it bubble massage the same name and
then he will wash you again and then
your threaten is going to be over its
traditional classical Turkish home on
the track although now veering slightly
off tradition I've been invited to take
what I've learned from arrow of living
excited
and apply it to my dear friends peace
ministers
[Music]
I know they can see some institution on
much
yes yes always feels really like the
field
I was trained by the best teacher is
when your day began today did you think
he'd ever seen by a Turkish man no
[Music]
give it yourself one of my favorite
things about traveling is the people you
can meet along the way and while I'm
sure I would have still had an amazing
time on my own I'm glad I got to share
this experience with a couple of guys
who had just as great a time as I did
and this Chaz put it best earlier in the
evening such an amazing placement when
you go and travel you get the experience
most cultures
I should do an anomaly he's just the
right thing to do to travel and to
friendship Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your partner subscribe here that was my
part